we've been told that they have found a
pope Shriners and we're just following
the kind investigation area for clues
you can eventually track whoever killed
this enemy
Nick can you pass us the big camera the
thing that you can't actually make out
is just how strong the smellier is
that's a really strong stench can I put
this one you just get a different
perspective is that Alright
I'll give a different angle records yeah
give a different angle perspective of
what the Gators are doing disturbing
I've seen a few of these and this is
just the beginning of our show the
extent have a little bit of time with
the mock but I mean there's reason again
you can actually feel okay
but animal dog unpredictable
huge like the more than 200 kilogram and
skittish running all over the place and
likely to whack into your bowl your
overall well you just don't know what
they're gonna do and that's the baby
what should we do
it's not gonna be enough she says I'm
staying near the gate which lady just
lets him come through
fine let's stand in your way
Nikki's feeling slightly compromised in
that position you got a 400 kg Rhino
trying to back you into a corner
your charm viewfinder you got either and
you get tacky lose peripheral vision so
you have these little monsters coming
yong-gu and they get taken out to be
that careful I am I saw what happened
now crazy dude
it's not over yet god you're crazy dude
getting up close and personal with
O'Reilly it's a nice smudge
right now they're in the fort
which means the fort is no longer a fort
fort has been compromised
I don't know much but Rhino body
language he doesn't in satisfaction
overlooked Nick loving it
lucky cat giving his tummy scratched
this is what makes the job